- [Tutor] What we're going
to discuss in this video
is the evolution of Japan
from being one of the most
isolated countries in the world
during the Tokugawa shogunate
to being the first Asian
country to truly industrialize
and become a world power.
Historians will often
categorize imperialism
or colonialism in one of two categories.
You have settler colonialism
and economic colonialism.
Settler colonialism is
exemplified by the Americas,
Australia, South Africa,
where you have the empire
sending people from their
country to settle that territory,
oftentimes displacing indigenous people
and becoming the ruling class.
Then you have economic colonialism
whose primary goal is to
feed the purported needs
of the Industrial Revolution.
India and Indonesia are
good examples of this.
You're looking for raw
materials to feed your
increased productivity,
and you're also looking for markets.
And so, in this context,
as we think about the evolution of Japan
from being extremely isolated
to becoming an imperial power,
think about which of these motivations
was primary to Japan.
Or maybe was there a third motivation?
Let's begin in the 19th century.
Japan is in control of
the Tokugawa shogunate,
who has closed the country to foreigners.
One of the purported reasons
is fearing the influence
of Christian missionaries as
early as the 17th century.
You have the British in India.
You have the Spanish who
have been in the Philippines
for several hundred years at this point.
You have the Dutch in control of much of
what will eventually be Indonesia.
This orange color shows where the French
already have a strong hold in
Indo-China and Southeast Asia.
And then this peach color,
this is what they would eventually control
as we get into the latter
half of the 19th century.
But to really understand
Japanese motivations in the 19th century,
you have to think about what
was happening in Qing China
as we talk about in the
video on the Opium Wars.
The British and other imperial powers
want access to Chinese markets.
The Europeans want Chinese
porcelain and Chinese silk.
But the Chinese weren't interested
in trading with the Europeans.
The Europeans, especially the British,
eventually do find
something the Chinese want
and that's opium, which
is an addictive drug.
It's the core ingredient
in heroin and in morphine.
The Chinese government of course
does not want that opium
inside the country,
but as we talk about in previous videos,
the British are able to force their way in
with the First Opium War,
often referred to as gunboat diplomacy.
And after winning the First Opium War,
the British are able to extract
concessions from the Chinese
including opening up these ports.
And even that does not
satisfy the British.
And so, you have the Second
Opium War from 1856 to 1860,
after which opium, this
addictive drug, is legalized.
And to make matters worse for China,
during the same period, they
have an incredibly bloody
civil war where over
20 million people die.
Historians think in part due
to the lack of confidence
in the Qing Dynasty
because of the Opium Wars
and the opium itself that is
very destructive to society.
Now, the Japanese were watching all this,
and they also had their own
interactions with the West.
In 1853, the American
Commodore Matthew Perry
comes in with some of his ships
into Edo Harbor, which
is modern day Tokyo,
and is able to convince the Japanese
to trade with the United States.
The term convinced should
be used very carefully
because once again, this was
a form of gunboat diplomacy.
The Japanese saw the ships
that Commodore Perry traveled with,
and they knew what had happened
during the First Opium War.
And they were in no mood
to have the same thing happen to them.
Especially when Commodore
Perry returned in 1854
with even more ships,
the Japanese decided,
why fight them?
We will open up and allow some trade.
And this is a very big deal.
Remember, the Tokugawa shogunate
had closed the country for over 200 years,
but now they saw the writing on the wall.
They could not defend themselves
against the American warships.
Like in China, these concessions
in Japan to the Americans
began to undermine trust
in the Tokugawa shogunate.
And to get a feel for
what people were thinking
in the mid-19th century in Japan,
we have some quotations
from Shimazu Nariakira,
who was the daimyo of Satsuma,
which is at the southern tip
of Japan right over here.
But he was considered to be a
leading thinker of the time.
And this photograph, it's not so clear,
but this is believed to
be the first photograph
taken by Japanese.
That gives you a sense of the time,
that photography daguerreotypes
were starting to be in use.
"It was inconceivable
that China would deteriorate
to such a degree."
Remember, we're talking
about the Opium Wars.
We're talking about the Taiping Rebellion.
"With its vast territory and population,
"there could not have been a dearth
"of loyal and devoted patriots.
"Yet since the Opium
War its administration
"has been in disorder and ineffective.
"It has been plagued by rebellion
"while England and France
have invaded it from without.
"Japan lies to the east of China,
"and is in such a
position as to necessitate
"immediate steps to prepare
against meeting the same fate
"as that which has befallen the Chinese;
"as soon as England achieves
its design in China,
"it will most certainly direct
its military might eastward.
"If we take the initiative,
we can dominate;
"if we do not, we will be dominated."
And this last sentence is often quoted.
"If we take the initiative,
we can dominate;
"if we do not, we will be dominated."
It's almost advocating for
a reactionary imperialism.
Become an empire or become
part of someone else's empire.
And this is the path that Japan goes down.
In 1867, you have the young
Emperor Meiji come to power,
who was only 15 or 16
years old at the time.
This would be the beginning
of what is known as the Meiji Restoration.
You could say that it's
a restoration of power
back to the emperor.
The emperor existed even
during the shogunate
but was a figurehead.
It was the shogun who had the power.
But now, the emperor was able to take back
the power from the shogunate.
But the Meiji Restoration is
perhaps even more important
in that it took Japan from
being a closed, feudal country,
and in only a few decades,
to a modern industrial imperial power.
Here are some data that
gives you a sense of this.
1875, 600,000 metric
tons of coal produced.
1913, 21.3 million.
So it's grown almost 40 fold.
1873, 26 steamships.
1913, 1,514 steamships.
Railroad track, 1872, only 18 miles.
By 1914, 7,100.
Emperor Meiji dies in 1912,
but as we get into 1914, you
start to see World War I.
And as we talk about in other videos,
this industrialization
of Japan allows it to be
a major actor in World War I.
As we exit the 19th century
and we also go to the 20th century,
we see Japan leveraging
its industrial might
that we see in numbers here
in terms of taking over territory
and becoming an imperial power.
In this flashing red, this is what Japan
is able to take over by
the end of World War II.
They were able to take over Korea
at the beginning of the 20th century.
And even though Hitler's
invasion of Poland
is often given as the
start of World War II,
Japan's occupation and
very brutal occupation
of Northeast China is often considered
the real start of World War II.
As World War II progresses,
Japan is able to take
more and more territory,
French Indo-China, British
Burma, the Dutch Indies,
Indonesia, Philippines.
And this empire only comes to an end
when Japan has to surrender
at the end of World War II in 1945.
So, go back to the previous question.
What type of colonial power was Japan?
It definitely wanted
the natural resources.
In fact, especially when it was at war,
it needed access to oil
which Indonesia had.
It needed access to natural resources
that all of these areas had,
but there was also this element
of wanting to be a major
player on the global stage
in fear that if it wasn't,
it might become a victim
of colonization itself.